so that Dwyer that sounds like in the
morning we met in college
my roommate in college was really good
friends with them and he thought we
wouldn't be a good match after it
happened after I realized my was that we
were not in the zoo and not a good match
so I'd say Eduardo's more type egg Chaz
is definitely a lot more like everyone
pay attention to me look at me I have
Eduardo seems to think that it's a good
idea for two people to do a two to six
person escape room well maybe if we
learn to communicate and work together
we could actually do it maybe she has a
terrible communicator what Chaz the type
of person we were dating he has read
receipts on and then he would read my
messages and then ignore them not ignore
I just like thought that is not answer
that's I ignore I different right so we
didn't really talk for a very long time
after the breakup today is an
opportunity to kind of put aside all the
baggage and be friends again hopefully
hopefully or maybe everything will be
worse after this all right let's do this
caper I'm Casey you are at enigma escape
room I'm gonna be your game master today
like the fire games a little bit you
guys have been given the location of a
secret temple but the keepers of those
secrets are on their way to you guys
right now so you guys have one hour
before the keepers arrive or else
alright we're all set up to go to the
escape room we've got these GoPros so
that we can get a little bit more
footage let's do it okay so do we start
right away I guess so
this says it to gain power over an
aching heart one must follow the wise
men's light to the cradled star in the
sky where you will discover the keys to
the temple of knowledge this is like a
mat well gained oh you have one hour
before the keepers arrive the room is
yours you may continue so like look for
an aching heart and wise men's light
like a light is that a wise man is that
his light
I guess can we open this can you turn
this upside down these are two things
here this is another thing this is
something because this is right across
from that this is something you slow
down no no no no just take take your
time relax okay
there's definitely something important
with the boat it's the USS Constitution
Oh what there's a little note in the
sail it says the US Constitution is a
wooden hold three-masted Heavy Brigade
named by President George ok wait that
says USS on it Oh three-masted heavy
forget oh one she is one three one six
try it yeah yeah all these cards I told
you it was in the letter
well I found the letter so okay well I
feel like the cards match up to this
yeah to gain power of an aching heart
there's a heart right here slighted
aching heart Wise Ones ladies miss Li
but then what does that mean oh there
are numbers at the bottom and it's a
code three nine one five
more numbers ah
these are glued in place because it's
the end of the sequence from eight five
zero got a caution laser and Paul now
reporters the keepers have left you a
test for your memory
I suggest flipping all of the switches
until you get the results that you see
wait we can do this more methodically no
no okay so where's a point a have we
seen that symbol before this one here
three that's three there's got to be
there's got to be like look there's a
number two there under the fourth under
the fourth
what's a far sweater oh is this I don't
know what a first is a merely easy part
okay well F thank you
under the farts of kept saying under the
earth lies a secret light though
illuminate the path the Stars will guide
you on your journey
oh there's a crank or what for cranky
this is a UV light how do we find star a
bit no it's gonna be on down on their
car on the ground wouldn't stars be up
because that's where stars go Yeah right
here this is lighting up follow the star
it's pointing that way found it so
that's what symbol is that that is six
there's clocks why are there two clocks
are they on different times
thumbs right and then that one is stuck
yeah you know how to tell time in order
yes it is for Santa's did you check that
clock before did you check this clock is
there any other important things so this
is the fourth numbers so the last number
is what isn't it I found a keypad
edoardo but we don't know what the third
number is right develop this this is the
key to that
doesn't even come off it's clearer than
their three six two nine three six two
nine great let's do stuff there's all
these turning hands
I see the hands jazz okay what is Amy
and this is my thing
I found a fee maybe try it on this thing
we're gonna have to crank something I'll
let a daughter do it cuz he's strong you
go got it now that you have proven
yourselves worthy I shall need a
volunteer to do some interdimensional
traveling with me now this brave soul is
going to be your media Oh God
oh my god explain that I see the room in
a very trippy 3d I wish either the VR oh
yeah this is awesome
this and over here is like this oh
they're different okay that hand over
there is facing down okay okay now these
hands I believe are in their proper
position we may return you to our
dimension wait where'd you find this in
the broken no it's always broken I
believe that book may give us an
indication on how to turn the final hand
do you need letters we ought to proceed
I would make sure to check every drawer
that you find
[Music]
ah yes toggle we're never reading a new
book I prefer to start with the title
ah oh is that a pop-up I'm just doing it
Sahgal SOG ol4 eight to nine hold us you
have to take this okay I can do it
ecstasy or something today
okey I would proceed with caution for we
do not know what lies beyond
Chow's we'll go first yes Wow
so yeah we just got out of the escape
room how did is it you guys did really
well especially for being just the two
of you guys wow you guys in the other
yeah oh we actually worked really well
together we do you think more exes
should do escape rooms together yeah it
very well could be the therapy that
couples or formal couples would mean how
you forget hug so I'm just games we did
it you guys continue to live
[Music]